[Music]  eddie you are a cancer to everyone who  ever loved you  [Music]  you know how much i love an underdog  eddie brock how come every time bad  things happen you seem to be at the  center and maybe i'm lucky  i've been thinking about you because you  and i  are the same  where are you going with this i'd like  you to meet  carnage  venom the chocolate delivery hasn't  arrived yet no i am happy to eat mrs  jack no no you cannot eat mrs chen what  nothing exclusively movie theaters  october 1st  eddie brock i want to give you my story  all my secrets  why me people love serial killers  that's mine it's yours  and what's yours is mine  and all i ever wanted in this circus of  hell  is carnage  exclusively movie theaters october 1st  [Music]  you